wie kann man sich denn immer für die
falsche Spur entscheiden
Auffrischung immer monatlich einfach
Nein
wie viele Gefahrenbremsung haben wir den
letzten 48 Stunden gemacht
ich habe tot sein können nein ich fahre
gut
dafür wenn einfach jemand drüber fährt
es ist Grünstraße heißt einfach
fressgasse
Studio
der Liebe Tätowierer hier in mir auf dem
Talent gesehen hat und meinte dass ich
ja auch mal vielleicht nicht ganz
Tätowieren setzen sollte deswegen hat
sich da unten und ganz ganz tolles Büro
ausgesucht richtig einfallsreich und
zwar
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht ich habe ein bisschen
Schiss ehrlich gesagt soll ich das jetzt
mit Smileys mit dem Stift wichtiges zu
beachten die hohe Stirn mach mir keine
Vorgaben
hier so haben oder eher hier so
was für eine stille auf einmal
ich will da auch ja
ich war damals 1844 habe ich den alten
Roman ein bisschen rein damit du mir
keine Narbe machen kannst ja
nicht vertrauen
[Musik]
wo keine Ahnung
ich wollte nicht weh tun
[Musik]
dass meine Farbe das mein
tätowierspritzt habe
[Musik]
sein Auto verkaufen können bist du
zufrieden mit der Meisterwerk
weil du tanzt wir waren jetzt gerade auf
jeden Fall die ganzen
Scheiß drauf
wir sind im Podcast Studio angekommen
wie gefällt dir
sehr geil
auf jeden Fall aus wir haben hier vorne
eine fette geile Backsteinwand mit einem
Dick und Doof Neon zahlen wir haben hier
verschiedene Bilder wo irgendwie nahezu
nur Sandra drauf ist hier sitzt sie mit
ihrer Figur das
brotlos so werdet ihr uns auf Spotify
sehen
Füße mich nicht an alter wir haben auch
keine richtigen Tische sondern wir haben
einfach reist auf kölschkissen genommen
wir haben überall Kölsch stehen wir
haben hier Kissen hier ist die Wand das
Handy und wir nehmen jetzt auf
noch die anderen Podcast Folge vor und
Luca geh mal auf dem Klo
ja lass mich jetzt wissen
Podcast Folge ist vorbei
mittlerweile führe ich übrigens einfach
eine Brieffreundschaft mit den Fans die
mir letztens einen Brief von meinen Tür
gelegt haben denn
die haben jetzt wieder was vor die Tür
gelegt danke euch Vivien alles Gute
nachträglich an der Stelle neue Tasche
gekauft und diese Tasche ist so klein
dass nicht mal das Portemonnaie
reinpasst das ist die auch mit Abstand
hässlichste Tasche die ich je gesehen
habe fragt sich schon die ganze Zeit wie
dieses Ding heißt also wie willst du das
nennen den Stuhl
Schreibtischstuhl ja aber wenn ich jetzt
nicht am Schreibtisch sitze
Drehstuhl ja aber mach keinen Sinn der
kann sich nicht nur Drehen der kann auch
Rollen Rollstuhl macht auch keinen Sinn
Rollstuhl ist das wo du drin sitzt und
dich voran rollst voll Drehstuhl
Leute kommentiert mal bitte wie das
heißt also wie heißt ein Stuhl mit
Rollen und zum drehen wenn ich nicht am
Schreibtisch sitze
wir erfinden hier neue Wörter
Goethe kann einpacken hat ihr schon
nichts er ist tot ich war gerade im Gym
und habe nach dem Training meine Mama
angerufen weil mir ein bisschen
schwindelig warm sie hat mir daraufhin
dann geantwortet trinkt doch mal ein
bisschen was
das ist genauso wie wenn du mir sagst
dein Handy ist kaputt und ich sag dir
dann mach es mal an und aus
dann bringt auch nichts muss man
eigentlich eine bestimmte Gewichtsklasse
erreicht haben um Fitnessstudio Gym zu
nennen
stabile Haare übrigens
keine Kopfhörer dabei
das heißt ich musste die ganze Zeit
irgendwelchen Leuten bei ihrem Bullshit
zuhören aus dem richtigen first life
Problems über die ich gerade Berichte
aber letzte Woche schon erzählt dass ich
so einen Gym Vertrag hier abgeschlossen
habe weil ich ja nur für zehn Wochen in
Hamburg bin nur für den Zeitraum
trainieren will blablabla ist auch
scheißegal darum soll es gar nicht gehen
die Sache ist nur dass ich dort in der
Vornamen Spalte mein vor und Zweitnamen
eingegeben habe
und jetzt bin ich heute abgecheckt aus
dem Gym und die Kassiererin da vorne an
der Rezeption sagt einfach tschüss Luca
Dilo
warum hat man zwei Namen
ich verstehe diesen Sinn nicht ich weiß
halt dass es früher bei mir so war dass
der Name Luca zumindest als ich geboren
wurde im Jahr 1996
nicht eindeutig ein Männername war
deswegen brauchte ich einen zweiten
[Musik]
ich brauchte auf jeden Fall einen
zweiten Namen der eindeutig zeigt dass
ich ein Junge bin
bro
frag mich was ich für ein Geschlecht
habe dann sage ich es dir wieso brauche
ich einen zweiten Namen ich hasse meinen
zweiten Namen absolute höher wäre es
noch gewesen wenn meine Eltern als
Zweitnamen nicht Tilo sondern Tino
genommen hätten das ist nämlich der hier
von Disneys Wochenend Kids
oder trauriges dass ich leider genauso
früher aussah können meine Freunde bitte
lernen ihre Sprachnachrichten kurz zu
halten
das ist eine Nachricht und kein Podcast
welchen Podcast hören würde ich die
Konto war neue Folge online auf Spotify
ich habe ein paar Stoppeln okay dass
Leute mit Glatze voll häufig im Bad
haben
bei euch wächst irgendwie falsch rum
so
das geht Leute ab jetzt blocke ich
einfach falsch rum das habe ich ganz
Hamburg für diesen Style gehatet dann
habe ich Peyton aus Glas weil sie selber
den Style hatte und jetzt trage ich ja
auch meine weiße Air Force mit einer
naja ich wollte jetzt mal ab war nämlich
irgendwie den ganzen Tag lang shoppen
was den ganzen Tag lang shoppen ne
chillige Belichtung gehalten ja das ist
ein neuer Trend
[Musik]